this year's microsoft e3 press  conference also dropped a few release  dates for Rico inside and the divisions  underground DLC recall will hit xbox one  and pc on sep tember 13 the robot heavy  game was shown off with a new gameplay  trailer during the conference which  introduced the cast of characters most  of which are brought to life by placing  an AI core into the shell of robots as  foreplay deaths dystopian adventure game  inside there really isn't long to wait  as you'll be able to pick it up on xbox  one on jun 29 and for pc come july seven  finally the divisions first paid  expansion underground will launch first  for xbox one on jun 28 it comes packed  with randomly generated missions and  deadly urban environments among other  things  you  you